she was just a great fun girl
um
yeah just lovely to be around
we just adored her
[Music]
the volcano has been erupting moderate
ways since about november december last
year
but this eruption on saturday afternoon
took people quite by surprise
on friday the 14th of january 2022 an
underwater volcano started to erupt off
the islands of tonga there is much we
don't know but there are fears tonga is
facing significant damage
the hunger tonga hungar hapai volcano
then erupted explosively on saturday
it's about 40 miles offshore of the
tongan capital nuku alofa
the eruption which was heard as far away
as the u.s caused meter-high tsunami
waves to crash into tonga
satellite imagery shows the potential
for major damage and more than 10 000
kilometers away two people drowned off a
beach in northern peru amid abnormally
high waves
she would walk into a room and just
lighten the room up and she
loved her life
fifty-year-old angela glover from
brighton who lived on tonga has been
confirmed dead her brother says her body
was found during a search organized by
her husband
james had
there's been a search party that
had been going on and i believe james
but i'm not too sure but i believe james
found the body and it was in some bushes
the words can't i can't even haven't got
the words in my vocabulary to even
describe how
we're
feeling
the key reason behind the lack of
information is communicating with tonga
has been extremely difficult
there's no internet and limited phone
calls because the fiber optic cable that
connects it with the rest of the world
was severed in the tsunami the company
that operates it says it will be weeks
before it's back up again
all 105 000 residents of the island
virtually uncontactable and has made
official reports of casualties virtually
impossible
the red cross estimates that up to 80
000 people may have been affected by the
tsunami
dust from the volcano could contaminate
water supplies with locals advised to
drink bottled water and wear masks
australia and new zealand have both sent
surveillance flights to the island and
have promised relief support as soon as
it is safe to do so a clear indication
that has come from tonga is the need for
water the ash cloud has as you can
imagine cause contamination that's on
top of already a challenging environment
in terms of water
supply and so that's what the defence
force are very focused on this isn't the
first time the volcano has erupted in
modern times events in 2014 and 2015
created an entire new island and
disrupted air travel for several days
things that we as aid agencies will be
looking at is those fresh water needs
that also of course impact on health and
hygiene we don't want to have a
secondary disaster of waterborne
diseases or
other health impacts so that is
definitely a key area
in terms of the the response this is
just a terrible shock
that's happened to us you know we're
we're ordinary people
stuff like this just doesn't happen to
people like us but then it does